during that campaign rally President
Trump had a warning for North Korea
should he attest a hydrogen bomb in the
Pacific Ocean
maybe something gets worked out and
maybe it doesn't but I can tell you one
thing you are protected okay you are
protected nobody's gonna mess with our
people the president referred to North
Korea's leader Kim jong-un as little
rocket man which drew cheers from the
audience joining us with more on this is
Sekulow kapoor national political
reporter for Bloomberg News good morning
Sahil morning with all of this tough
talk is there a diplomatic way out of
the North Korea situation well it
depends on what you define as a way out
right previous presidents have dealt
with the nuclear North Korea and if the
end game is containment preventing the
Kim regime from using nuclear weapons
against his neighbor to the south or
against other US allies then yes it's
doable President Obama did it George
Elbe Bush did it but this regime this
country is already the most isolated in
the world they've been hit with lots and
lots of economic sanctions and it's
unclear that they're going to give up
their nuclear weapons it's highly
unlikely in fact because that is the one
piece of ammunition they have to survive
and to defend themselves we heard
President Trump obviously addressing
North Korea when he was talking with the
UN General Assembly this week his first
address to them how did his America
first agenda play a couple of things I
mean I think the president did hit on
what a lot of Americans feel on their
gut that the United States has
overextended in the world that it's
doing too much that it's looking after
too many other countries when it should
be looking after itself I think you know
he played into that very well but there
were some contradictions in what he said
and and that what there wasn't I think
was a clear path forward a clear
strategy so for instance he talked about
not taking in refugees into the United
States and instead resettling them in
their home countries but his budget cuts
foreign aid pretty substantially which
the government only spends about what is
only about 1% of what the government
already spends he talked about pulling
back from the world but he's doubling
down on the Afghanistan strategy he's
making threats to Assad in Syria so
where the trade-offs are where the
policy is going forward
still a lot of questions let's talk
about health care so he'll as Paula Reid
mentioned John McCain is an O which
means the Republicans can't afford to
lose one
or vote and Susan Collins of Maine is is
on me is on the edge here of voting no
you've talked to her several times this
week
can they get her to yes do you think it
looks increasingly unlikely by the day
she has said she's concerned about this
bill her latest is she said she's
leaning against it she has expressed
concerns specifically with one aspect of
the bill regarding pre-existing
conditions what the bill allows states
to do is to get a waiver that says
insurers cannot turn people away but
they can't charge sick people more
people would grieve those in conditions
more this was one of the core features
of Obamacare also known as the
Affordable Care Act and it's one of the
reasons they had all these other
unpopular provisions to help balance
that out so she's concerned with you
know with with that among other things I
think the Medicaid aspect of it that's
what this bill would cut federal funding
especially Medicaid and her state is one
that benefits from that a lot so she's
looking like a very likely no at this
point we know that trump administration
needs a policy win would the president
be better served going with a bipartisan
route at this point on health care there
are certainly Republicans who think that
there was Lamar Alexander the chairman
of the Health Committee in the Senate
who had been negotiating with patty
Murray his Democratic counterpart and I
think the resurfacing of the ACA repeal
effort scuttled that negotiation that
remains to be seen if that'll come up
again but yes to your point this issue
threatens to become an albatross around
the neck of the Republican Party and
they can't either succeed at a repeal
bill or find a way to move on and make
peace with it
so you think it's I mean but is there
can these guys actually talk to each
other at this point the politics are
still pretty lethal in the party so I
think something's gonna have to happen
before right in their own party yes heel
Cupp words thank you very much for being
with us this morning
thank you